Death strandings opening hours are harsh
accomplishing objectives and delivering
cargo is simple enough but navigating
the game's bizarre often treacherous
world is the biggest challenge a sand
porter bridges your goal is to connect
dozens of weigh stations to what's known
as the chiral network this is no easy
task as there are plenty of obstacles
that stand in your way of accomplishing
this
if death strandings first three chapters
have thrown you into hardship then you
come to the right place slow and steady
gets you through tough terrain when you
take your first steps during the opening
hours you'll immediately notice that
even basic movements feel particularly
demanding there's a purpose for this and
it's all about putting you in the shoes
of a delivery man carrying a heavy load
of valuable cargo across treacherous
landscapes
unlike other open-world games we're
covering large amounts of ground can be
easy
dust stranding has a considerably slower
pace your intended to travel across long
stretches carrying tons of cargo but if
you're not smart about how you navigate
the environment Sam can quickly lose his
footing and eat dirt
slow and steady movement is the name of
the game and death stranding and you'll
need to be constantly aware of the
topography you're walking across take it
slow and pay attention to the surface as
you're walking be weary of rocks and
steep inclines by using the Odra deck
Sam shoulder-mounted robot assist you
can better evaluate the finer details on
the ground ahead of you
surfaces mark blue by the scanner are
safe to walk across while ground marked
yellow should be approached with caution
if it's marked red such as deep rivers
or rough surfaces and you're better off
avoiding them entirely there'll be some
cases where you'll have to traverse
across tough terrain with tons of cargo
and when that happens
be sure to exercise caution if you're
ever afraid of how you might cross a
terrain start by holding the shoulder
buttons to stabilize your center of
gravity and walk through it first before
picking up the pace inventory management
101 a crucial part of deaths stranding
is managing and expanding your inventory
depending on how you choose to organize
your backpack and other inventory slots
Sam's poise posture and speed will be
affected you can eventually acquire
exoskeletons to boost the overall carry
limit but it's essential to understand
the basics in the beginning first you
need to ensure that you're keeping track
of what's on your body at all times
while exploring it can be easy to pick
up stray cargo and before you know it
you'll find that Sam's stamina is
reduced and his ability to balance is
negatively impacted there's a
consequence for every item added to your
inventory if you're not careful even if
you're far under the carry limit you can
still notice an impact on your movement
speed and balance with enough things
stacked on you once Sam's backpack fills
up he'll eventually begin to stack
objects on top of his backpack while
this is fine for a few items a full
stack of cargo can make it difficult for
Sam to maintain his balance it's
especially noticeable when walking as
making slight movements to the left or
right can cause Sam to struggle under
the weight prompting you to grip on to
his backpack to avoid tumbling to the
ground failure to counteract a loss of
balance will cause Sam to fall and his
cargo to tumble out of his pack
while you can organize your backpack
manually you also have the option to
have the game arrange it for you by
pressing the triangle button in the
inventory menu you can quickly optimize
your cargos layout placing heavy objects
at the bottom and filling out other
cargo slots on Sam's suit it's a useful
feature for optimizing Sam's loadout and
ensuring you have the best posture
possible however a downside to this is
that the auto arrange option won't
acknowledge sensitive cargo regardless
always be aware of what's in your
inventory though you may be tempted to
stuff everything in your backpack your
sometimes better off rearranging an item
offloading it or holding in your hand
get to know the Preppers to build a
stable future for the united cities of
america you'll need to ensure that
precious cargo makes its way back to
those and need across the nation
throughout the game you'll come across
shelters housing Preppers which will
eventually request Sam's services after
you complete enough deliveries you'll
increase your connection with that
prepper in addition to getting new story
details and info on Preppers in the area
you can also unlock new gear for Sam one
of the more useful upgrades is the
backpack cover which is obtained from
the collector in the central region
you'll need to pick up loose cargo for
them to connect to the chiral network
the cover will protect the backpacks
contents from exposure for a set amount
of time which can be invaluable when the
going gets tough take time to increase
your rankings with the Preppers as the
tools and gadgets that give you can be
life savers in your journey how to deal
with BTS as you explore the world you'll
encounter beached things otherwise known
as BTS
these BTS are ghostly apparitions that
will try to cling tightly to any living
thing that approaches them they
typically accompany time fall but you'll
specifically know they're around when
the game shifts into slow motion briefly
to focus on your order duck shrieking at
their presence early on it's best to
sneak past BTS and use your bb's senses
to approximate their location to keep an
eye on nearby BTS pay attention to which
direction you're owed your deck is
pointing when it starts to flap and
flash when you stand still and use the
Oder deck scanner you'll be able to use
echolocation to ping nearby beetee's
for a short time once you've tagged them
stand still at any time to see where
they're floating as you push further
make sure to keep sending a scan with
your odd reductive ping beat ease ahead
of you by crouching and holding your
breath with r1 you should be able to
avoid them but get too close and they'll
quickly pick up your trail take your
time when navigating past pts be too
hasty and you're asking for trouble if
BTS managed to see you things start to
get crazy
tar will cover the ground surface and a
group of BT's will try to pull you under
to avoid getting caught in their
clutches quickly mash the square button
to resist and hold the shoulder buttons
to stabilize your balance when prompted
if the bt successively pull you under
you'll be dragged across the ground and
left to face a much larger and more
dangerous bt at this point a sea of tar
will flood the vicinity while buildings
and debris emerge from the ground early
on you don't have much in the way of
defending yourself against BTS so the
best option upon being detected is to
escape the tar covered area as soon as
possible should you fail either by
getting pulled under or your health
being depleted you'll lose all your
cargo and you'll have to respond smash
that like button as dire Hardman States
in one of the game's many interviews
getting a quick light can give a person
a feeling of acceptance and
acknowledgement while this may seem like
a super on-the-nose commentary on the
influence of social media amassing and
giving out likes and death stranding is
a worthwhile pursuit by pressing the ps4
touchpad Sam can get kudos to structures
and signs made by other players that
show up a near instance of the world
while the game doesn't allow you to
interact with players explicitly liking
their structures as a way of connecting
with them more indirectly getting likes
will add to your total pool of social
cash which will increase your reputation
as a porter moving up the ranks will
earn sam bonuses to his attributes such
as boosting his carrying capacity and
posture when under stress every once in
a while you can also come across roaming
NPCs being friendly with them will earn
you some praise and even some freeing
gear from them
help your fellow Porter if you feel that
sending a like isn't enough and you want
to be more proactive about making a
difference in the game's world then you
can start by building structures or
helping other players by returning their
drop of cargo these actions can go a
long way in getting other players
situated in the world even if you're
alone traversing through the landscape
of ruined America your choices and
actions can leave a lasting impact while
setting up ladders and ropes can be
helpful to you they proved to be far
more useful for those that will be
following in your footsteps anyone that
uses any of your structures will also
send you a like which will feed into
your broader social cache building your
structures such as bridges or
watchtowers can be a great help for
other players but also goes both ways as
other players can construct objects to
help you in your journey you can even
contribute resources and supplies to
their structures such as bridges or
roads and that only helps the player
that started the creation but it will
also score you a considerable amount of
likes by investing in their structure
how to reorder lost cargo you'll neva
tably take a nasty spill when making a
delivery while you'll get yourself up
with minimal damage there are other
cases where you and your cargo will
tumble down a steep hill or worse into a
body of water
if this happens there's a solid chance
that you'll lose your cargo or it'll
suffer severe damage if this happens
don't fret in the orders tab of the
pause menu you can reorder lost cargo
doing so will reset the cargo back to
where you first picked it up allowing
you to try again however if the cargo is
considered destroyed then that special
delivery will be regarded as a failure
how to deal with mules mules are
abandoned like crew of unofficially
sanctioned delivery men that live for
the high of making deliveries so much so
that they're willing to attack innocent
Porter's and steal their cargo to get it
you typically run into them at their
camp spread across the world
they're often situated on the way
towards significant delivery stations so
you'll usually have no choice but across
their territory mules attack on site so
it's essential to stay hidden at least
if you want to pass without causing any
trouble
it's pretty easy to sneak past mules as
there aren't a lot of them in a camp
you'll find a few patrolling the
outskirts either on foot or in a truck
but as long as you cut through the small
pockets of open space between them you
can typically emerge unscathed despite
your best efforts to be sneaky you're
likely to encounter trouble from the
mules scanning pylons which periodically
trigger as you travel through their
territory when a scan initiate any mark
cargo on Sam will get pinged alerting
meals to the location it was last picked
up if mules corner you into a fight the
best strategy is to either punch them or
run for your dear life if you choose the
latter
try not to sprint in a straight line as
they're quick to throw their shock
Spears ahead of you which upon contact
cannot cargo from your backpack and
temporarily halt your movement feeling
tired
take a breather if you want to ensure
Sam is in top form but you're too far
from a private room for rest then you
can sit down and take a breather by
holding the circle button during this
position Sam can massage his shoulders
and even take a nap
he will also talk in his sleep if you
wait long enough by taking a nap you can
fully restore the stem and a meter but
to take full advantage of the rest make
sure you're on a flat surface if you
rest on a slope or rocky surface your
stamina recovery time will be cut by
half another way to speed up the process
is to rest next to a holographic Karen
which looks like a small stack of rocks
these are the former rest spots of other
players and staying near one will make
Sam feel more relaxed unlike private
rooms however the recovery process
happens in real time so time won't
advance as quickly as staying in your
room those are just a few tips to get
you started in death stranding anything
we missed
let us know in the comments below for
more tips and guides undeath stranding
head over to GameSpot and thanks for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]